autism research autism has been very
much in the news lately and it's pretty
much everywhere you look it's been a
really remarkable thing to watch just as
a phenomenon of watching people become
very interested in it my younger sister
is autistic and when I was a child the
only thing I knew about autism was the
fact that Karen was autistic now it
seems to be in the news everywhere
what's known about autism the number one
thing that's known about autism is that
it seems to be largely genetically
determined
if one identical twin is autistic then
the odds of the other twin having some
kind of autism spectrum disorder is
between 50 and 80 percent and that's
just a tremendous probability and that's
not the case for non identical twins for
fraternal twins and so that's a major
piece of evidence that autism is largely
genetic and one big story in the last
five years has been the identification
of genes that that increase the risk of
autism and it's not one gene it seems to
be some more complex polygenic disorder
where you get dealt a bunch of genes
from your mother and your your father
from your father and if you draw the
wrong combination of genes say between
two and ten genes then that increases
the risk of being autistic so that's the
main thing that's known as far as as far
as the the later development of it
people are starting to look at
structural differences between the
brains of autistic people and what are
called neurotypical people and those are
changes that take place in the neocortex
which is the largest part of our brain
and also in the cerebellum which people
used to think of as being a sensory or
motor structure but seems to be perhaps
important also for for more advanced
cognitive tasks and so the cerebellum as
has been fingered in the last few years
as far as treatments for autism right
now the one kind of treatment that seems
to be somewhat helpful is behavioral
therapy especially when children are
diagnosed and identified as needing the
help young and so that is interesting
because it's the one way that seems to
possibly help kids who have autism and
it may be part of why diagnosis rates
have gone up because it's recognized
that those therapies can help kids and
so people are motivated to identify
these problems in their kids when
they're young because that's when it's
possible to maybe catch these things and
and help these kids integrate better
into the rest of society
one characteristic of autism therapy in
the last few years has been basically
taking autistic kids and seeing what can
be done to help them and I think that's
sort of I wouldn't call it palliative
but it's it's in the category of helping
kids who are already diagnosed with
autism who have already been through a
lot of the developmental stages that
lead to autism and it's um and in some
sense the horses out of the barn and
then it's a question of what you can do
to help these kids - to bring to them
the kind of social skills that would
help them work much better in society I
think treatment is a ways away it's um
it's not in the next five years or even
next ten years but I think that
understanding the mechanisms in
development that lead to autism could
eventually lead to some kind of therapy
that could perhaps nip autism in the bud
when kids are you know when their brains
are making these developmental choices
early in life so I think it's a ways off
but I think the research starts pointing
towards better therapies
there are cases of people who can
perform astounding mathematical feats
with their brains and and to my
knowledge it is not well understood
exactly what it's doing there one way to
think about it is that our brains are
kind of sloppy we have these shortcuts
and tricks that our brains use honed
over millions of years of evolution to
come up with quantitative intuitions
about the world and there's something
that's possible that most of us don't
tap and what's interesting is the idea
that these people use other algorithms
entirely that somehow they've run across
to perform their mathematical feats I
think it's not well understood and I'm
not sure that that we're in a position
right now to understand how they do that
well once art had something going right
it didn't he write to Uncle Tony little
star when he was six you know I look I
mean no offense to most of the world's
six-year-olds but you know most
six-year-olds aren't writing tunes that
survived across the ages
so clearly Mozart had something going in
the case of Einstein Einstein was a very
very smart man who in his 20s made a
series of discoveries in rapid
succession that completely upended our
understanding of the world but one thing
he had as well was he was thinking very
hard about these problems he had a
patent clerk job that allowed him to
think hard about physical problems you
know kind of on the side and so he was
given the opportunity to to daydream a
little bit on the job and that was that
was pretty valuable